about your marriage your love story how
it all started and this is to set the
record straight mostly women in Dallas
got their rich husbands because at one
point they were on their knees under his
desk right that's what I know of Kari
okay a lot of what was said was true we
did work together and we did end up
getting together and we're married now
and you know what things like that
happen we did not sneak around and have
an affair I mean we definitely got
together quickly after he got separated
but there was a line drawn
Heidi is friends with marks ex-wife and
I think enough people are still friends
with her two will never accept carry
because of how she and Mark got together
actually actually my ex-wife doesn't
know her and and she even said that she
doesn't know my ex-wife yeah even though
it was said on the show that she did she
actually went on the record saying that
she didn't know my ex-wife got it Heidi
did not know your ex-wife she did not
know me do not know mark it was still
unclear from the show that Heidi did not
know yeah I know I guess people can just
say whatever they want you know I mean
they can make up their own false truth
which I guess you kinda have to deal
with when you're